joe dispenza went from competing in a
triathlon getting run over by an suv and
breaking his back in six places to
healing himself instead of taking
high-risk surgeries and teaching people
around the world how they can step
beyond their limitations and heal
themselves here's my take on his top 10
muscle success enjoy
[Music]
when you begin to create from the field
instead of from matter
the only way you can do that is you have
to learn how to take all of your
attention off your body and become a
nobody
take all of your attention off all the
people in your life that you give so
much of your attention and energy to
because you have an emotion associated
with them and get beyond all the people
in your life and go from a someone to a
no one
now if you've worked your whole life
being a someone or if you've been
working your whole life thinking that
you're your body you're gonna have to
work a little harder because that's your
identity that's what you're associated
with and it's a long time of
conditioning it's a long time
and if this was easy
everybody would be doing it so then you
have to go
get beyond all the things in your life
your cell phone your computer your car
and literally go from something to
nothing you have to take all your
attention off the place you work the
place you live the place you need to be
the place you're sitting and go from
somewhere to nowhere
you got to stop thinking about the
predictable future in the familiar past
and go right into the present moment and
go from some time to no time and if you
do that properly
you become pure consciousness and that's
how you enter the field
now we've done the research on this we
call it getting beyond the self now once
you are pure consciousness
you're taking all of your attention off
this three-dimensional reality now where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy so if you've taken all
of your attention off of everything
material
there's only one place you're going to
wind up and that is the in immaterial
realm called the quantum field an
invisible field of energy that unifies
and connects everything material
so now when you're creating from the
field and you combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
connected and you feel connected
the suggestion of an alternative way to
create
is that when there's a vibrational match
between your energy
and some future reality
you actually no longer have to go
anywhere to get it you're actually the
vortex and you will collapse space and
time and draw the experience to you now
that to me
is a lot more fun
because the experience
is the unknown you can't predict when
it's going to happen or how it's going
to happen because if you can predict it
it's known
so then you have to lay down the very
thing
you use your whole life to get what you
want
for something greater to occur now that
goes against
generations untold of conditioning and a
lifetime of habituation believing that
we're
trapped in this material world and yet i
can i can say to you without a doubt
that once you understand that formula
and once you know how to create that
kind of brain and heart coherence
the side effect of that
is a change in biology
neurologically chemically hormonally
genetically we've measured it we've seen
gene regulation changes in four days
more brain coherence more heart
coherence your brain's working better
your heart is you're trusting your heart
it's open there's different chemicals
that are released oxytocin suppresses
survival centers resets the baseline of
a person's trauma or shock
your immune system goes up
you you lengthen your telomeres we've
measured that too so you're changing the
future of your body you're extending
your life
that's evidence right so we we have the
evidence to know that it could happen
because we've measured it but the real
evidence
is watching the testimonial of someone
who says i had stage four cancer
i was told
as a 41 year old woman that i wouldn't
live for more than two months
and i have no
evidence of cancer in my body at all or
someone that's a physician who has
parkinson's disease that's tried
everything from the medical route and
has one transcendental moment and their
tremors and their pain are gone
now they're chewing food they're
swallowing
they're blowing their nose they're
standing up on their own
that's energy affecting matter so we
have
hundreds and hundreds of testimonials
of people that not only healed their
body
but created pretty profoundly magical
things in their life
so you have evidence in the scientific
world you have evidence in the practical
world and evidence
is the loudest voice right now rule
number two recondition your brain the
brain is a record of the past it's an
artifact of everything we've learned and
experienced to this moment
so
most people wake up in the morning and
they think about their problems and
their problems are memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and certain problems
at certain times in certain places and
the moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
the challenge is that every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it and emotions really are a record of
the past so the moment you feel unhappy
the moment you feel suffering the moment
you feel
fear now your body's in the past so it's
the thought being the language of the
brain and the feeling being the language
of the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so many
people reaffirm their state of being
completely
by the past and so it only takes a
thought and a feeling an image an
emotion
a stimulus and response to start the
conditioning process so we start to
condition the brain and body hardwire
the brain condition the body emotionally
into the past the problem is the body's
so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
we're creating by memory alone the
body's believing it's living in the same
past environment 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year so
then the person gets up and then they
run through the same routine as they
always do and
in time their body moves into a state of
autopilot now their body is a set of
programs a habit that's dragging them
into the same future based on what they
did in the past and so to change them
also requires being greater than the
emotions that have been conditioned into
the body and the habituations that have
been conditioned into the body in the
predictable future so
we have to understand then that change
requires not only being greater than the
environment
but also being greater than our body
which is really for the most part been
conditioned to be the mind that's what a
habit is
so then
to change then to be greater than the
body to be greater than the environment
and be greater than time instead of
living in the familiar past which is the
known and the predictable future which
is the known you teach people how to
settle into the present moment and
that's the unknown and most people that
the unknown represents a very
threatening place and so when people
start to do meditation as an example and
their body starts looking for an arousal
wants to get up and do things they think
they can't meditate but in fact if they
can settle their body back down into the
present moment and lower the volume to
that anger to that frustration to the
fear to the sadness
it's like training an animal now you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and our research
shows there's a liberation of energy the
body starts expanding and relaxing into
the present moment instead of getting up
and checking your cell phone and doing
something and you notice that propensity
instead of responding to it and say i
can't meditate you settle your body back
down into the present moment now you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
set of programs and it's the act of
doing this to be greater than the
conditions our environment to be greater
than our body is the mind and and to be
greater than time it all of a sudden
causes the person to start believing in
themselves a little bit more and that's
when
possibility starts to unfold rule number
three step into the unknown let's say
you've had some pretty rough experiences
in your past
and those experiences caused you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental
that
that's just
feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say
today
i'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about
two hours
and all of a sudden
the moment you realize that you're no
longer making the same choices
as the day before
you are going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain
there's going to be some
unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change
but now remember
95 percent of who you are
is your body as the mind
you know you've done something enough
times that your body does it better than
your brain
so you may actually
complain unconsciously because your body
does it all the time
and all of a sudden you say no
complaining
no more blaming no more feeling sorry
for myself no more talking about other
people i'm gonna stop
you know what happens don't you
the body
starts sending signals to the brain
the body's been conditioned that way
and all of a sudden you start hearing
the thoughts in your head
that say why don't you start tomorrow
tomorrow's a better day
this is too hard for me i can't change
something's wrong with me it's my
mother's fault it's my ex-husband's
fault it's my ex-wife's fault i'm this
way because of this event or the most
important one
this
doesn't feel right
and the moment you respond to that
thought
as if it's true
that thought
leads to the same choice which leads to
the same behavior that creates the same
experience that produces the same
emotion and the person says this feels
right
that feels
familiar going from the old self to the
new self
stepping into that void stepping into
that uncertainty
is the biological
the neurological the chemical the
hormonal genetic death of the old self
and people will say to us
well in that unknown i can't predict my
life or my future
and we always say the same thing to them
the best way to predict your future is
to create it
not from the known but from the unknown
and when you and i get comfortable in
the place of the unknown that's where
the magic happens
and it never happens in the known rule
number four open your heart if you have
a very brain driven person like myself
and in some parts i disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
and it's a challenge for me to reconnect
to my old emotions that i already had in
circumstances that would help
do you have any advice
yeah well uh god i have a lot of advice
around that
because um
seventy percent of the time that people
in their waking lives
uh they live in a very protective state
they live in a state of stress or in a
state of survival in fact it's such a
program
that we don't know that we're doing this
we're always
spanning the environment to determine if
it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us
and we move into a state of arousal and
we begin to turn on the very systems
that begin to say danger threat
possible scenario that's not
safe
and when that happens
we literally begin to anticipate an
outcome
and when we do that we're always
preparing
for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety
worry
sadness pain we do that unconsciously
that's what a program is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide
and show a certain amount of success
and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet um in our work
i see men that if they practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering
being free being allowing yourself to
let go
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five change your
personality we're all faced with
uh
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations
and there's always a door there is
always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this show has created the
present personal reality called their
life which means if you're going to
change something in your personal
reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change
nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
you change but you the thought of
changing my personality seems so like
but i like who i am kind of but
i'm also cranky i'm also annoyed
so
like who is that person underneath
all of these ailments i guess all of
these
but it's a weird thing to say you change
your personality
well look i mean there's many things
that i love about my personality just
like you do i'm going to take that with
me but there are things if i'm going to
be defined by a vision of the future
there are things that can't come because
the moment you say i want to have a
mystical experience where i transcend
this three-dimensional world and
and you want to have a really profound
moment a transcendental moment
you start showing up for that and it
doesn't happen right away then what
you're going to start disbelieving you
start to stop believing in yourself
though so the moment we're defined by a
vision of the future that's bigger than
us
that vision of the future is not the
vision of the past and when we do that
we take away we take with us
our discipline we take our concentration
we take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us
all those things you take
but the things that are standing in the
way are those old beliefs and things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and
it's not the it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and
so many great people in history you know
even wealthy people people always want
to be wealthy but if you study wealthy
people that really did it they failed
miserably thousands of times until they
figured it out and so you keep showing
up for yourself
enough times
they're going to change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation rule
number six open your focus when a person
begins to slow their brain waves down
they have to go when you're in stress
when you're in survival you narrow your
focus on a cause that's called a what's
called a convergent focus so now you're
blessing the energy centers of the body
they're under the control of the
autonomic nervous system and when the
autonomic nervous system moves out of
balance the brain moves out of balance
right we narrow our focus on the cause
and it causes each one of these
different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into incoherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers or
we pro reprogram these energy centers
two things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta state and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow focus
to a broad focus when you open your
focus when you open your awareness
that's what creates coherence in the
brain because you're going against that
habit
of putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
divergent focus which is focusing on
energy well reality is both particle and
wave matter and energy so if a person
can slow their brain waves down from
beta brain waves to alpha brain waves
now they're starting to fall out of
their thinking brain
right into the home of the autonomic
nervous system okay the person can't
change their brain waves it'll never
work because they're in their neocortex
and their thinking mind right
so that's one thing that has to happen
the second thing that has to happen is
that they have to practice both a
convergent focus and a divergent focus
now by the convergent you're focusing on
let's say i'm going to focus on this
energy center right and then you move
your focus to another energy first you
first you focus on that energy center
that's particle and then you focus on
the space around it that's wave okay and
so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
in
your sexual organs you move to your
second center you put your attention
there that's your where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so now you're beginning to direct energy
yeah into that center but now you become
aware of the space around why to create
coherence in that little brain send the
coherent message to the cells and
tissues go to your third center right in
the pit of your gut well there's a huge
celiac plexus there solar plexus a lot
of connections in there so now put your
big one that's a bit always getting a
lot of signs there yeah here and here
yeah and solar plexus yeah that's those
are big ones and you tune into that
energy then you put your attention in
your heart it has its own individual
brain yeah and when you make energy here
when energy finally arrives here guess
where it goes automatically
straight up we've measured it so now
once you start opening your heart you
got more energy in your heart you get
more energy in your brain got it short
on time just go straight to the heart
that's why we do it that's exactly why
we that's why we open the heart so it
creates a field and it begins to drive
energy of the brain so now that energy
is going to cause the person
to have a different consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
um
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can master convergent and diverge and
focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
expressions rule number seven be a
creator not a victim would you say it's
smart to focus on one goal i mean if
you're sick obviously
it's it's smart to focus on only getting
healthy but if you have a regular life
and you say you know i would like to
have the classical stuff more money
more wealth more
love more joy
would you say in those meditations it's
smart to focus on different goals or
should it rather be the big goal like a
big vision i have for my life that all
the steps on the way are just
marks i will pass at one point well
let's answer that on two levels too
because people come to our workshops for
all different reasons some people come
because they're sick
some people come because they want more
money some people want more a new job a
new opportunity a new career a new
relationship some people want the
mystical
the people come for all kinds of reasons
to me
i don't care
what i care about
is that they latch on to a vision
and they learn
how
to create
whatever drives them to that elegant
moment
where they're so present and so
passionate about what they want and they
have a clear intention a clear vision a
coherent brain
and they have an elevated emotion
combined with it that they create hard
coherence and now they're broadcasting a
whole new energy
into the field and whatever we broadcast
into the field
is our experiment with destiny
so i want people
to know the how
because we have plenty of people that
have made millions and millions of
dollars that were living in the back
seat of their car or filed bankruptcy
plenty of people that were stage four
cancers serious health conditions that
are healed but really
people think they come for those reasons
but we come for wholeness
that's why we come that when we feel so
whole
and so happy with ourselves so
connected to something greater
if you feel wholeness
it's impossible for you to want
how can you want when you're whole when
you're whole you feel like you have
everything
so
i want people
to reach that point
where
they feel so whole
that they no longer want and that's when
the magic happens teaching them that
allows them to understand that when they
come back to their senses
they open their eyes
they're not looking
for the experience they feel like it's
already happened and if you feel like
it's already happened why would you be
looking for it
then
if your body is conditioned emotionally
into that future
um you're not separate from the energy
of your future you're connected from it
to it but the moment you get in traffic
and you start getting angry
you get on the line at the bank and you
start getting impatient or you're
sitting in a staff meeting you start
judging a co-worker
you just disconnected from the energy of
the future and now you're back to the
energy of your past and you've done
nothing wrong
you just lost your connection to the
future now now the importance of that is
to notice that you're disconnected and
if you say to me well that person
made me feel this way and think this way
i'd say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
i think and feel
but a person who's producing outcomes in
their life
all of a sudden they say wow the way i'm
thinking and feeling is creating
outcomes in my life
now i'm a creator of my life and now i
believe less and i'm a victim of my life
rule number eight keep learning new
things i want to show you what it looks
like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections
if you took
a hundred thousand hundred billion
sheets of paper and you stack them on
top of each other it would be five
thousand miles high that's the distance
from los angeles to london
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections
now
i'll stop right after this slide
learning
is making new synaptic connections
every time you learn something new this
is what's happening in your brain
geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today
your brain did this
boom
that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint
if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them and all of a sudden
they develop a long-term relationship
and just like any relationship the more
you communicate the more they connect
and neurons are exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves
into networks or what's called neural
networks
and neural networks are just gangs of
neurons
that have fired and wired together to
form a community of neurosynaptic
connections that's related to a thought
a skill a habit a behavior a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic rule number nine shift your
mindset people think that
they want certain things because they're
experiencing lack
and and so
they have to go about
becoming
the very person so then if we reframe it
and you say oh i really want to be
wealthy i want all my needs met and i'll
say really why you want to be wealthy
and they'll say because i want freedom
i'd say okay let's focus on freedom
so now the person understands the
sponsoring thought or the emotion
why would you wait for your wealth to
feel free that's the newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack
and what if i'm feeling this emotion
this emotion is influencing certain
thoughts and how i think and feel
creates my life if i'm living in lack
i'm not going to create anything new
but if i say to you hey
when you become that person
once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause an effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become
and all of a sudden now the emphasis or
the
interest is in becoming that person and
we have a week with those people and i
want them to walk as it sit as it stand
as it lay down as it i want them to get
in the habit of walking from their room
to the ballroom it's become the new
habit that's why when we do our work
you're we're doing sitting meditations
we're doing standing and walking
meditations we're doing lying down
meditations i want it to become a new
habit i want them to become that person
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is shorten
emotional reactions one of my biggest
problems is that i tend to react quickly
to negative situations
how how can i cope with
anger do you have any suggestions or
advice
yeah i'll tell you the first thing
it's not that you react we all react
the question is how long
are you going to react that's the
question so
we found out that when people react
emotionally with anger
uh with antagonism
uh there's an arousal that takes place
because you're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous system is a
primitive system saying alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my god
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they they they flee they're in fear
they're like the fear is i'm better just
getting away so they they their fear
causes them to run
uh
so
uh when people feel fear when they feel
anger when they feel pain
those are the primary
stimulators that switch on that
sympathetic nervous system and they used
to say
that it's automatic
like it's automatic it happens
automatically that's part of the
autonomic nervous system and you really
don't have any control of it turns out
that's absolutely not the truth so first
thing
is learning how to shorten
your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and i say
alex why are you so mad today and you
say oh it's because of this situation
and this person this happened this way
and i would say oh my gosh do you mean
that that person or that circumstance
is controlling
the way you feel
and the way you think
now anything that's controlling the way
we feel in the way we think makes us
victims
whatever that is now
that's okay
but if you keep that emotional reaction
going on
for hours or days and i say to you alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me i'm i'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago i'd say you
have a mood
you're in a mood now some people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then i would say
well alex has a
angry
temperament it becomes a temperament
if we keep it going for now this is true
people keep this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait
so here's the weird part about it
you ask that person who's been angry for
years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago
or a series of events from 10 years ago
and there was
yeah and the research on the memory says
that 50 of that story
isn't even the truth
that they can't even remember the truth
they embellish the story
and make it sound worse than it really
was to excuse themselves from changing
now
what we tell people is
forget
the event
doesn't matter
the details of the event doesn't what
matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused and it
starts getting frustrated and it starts
getting angry and people say i'm doing
my meditation wrong you know what i say
to them no no no no you're doing it
right
because that has to come up so then
so when they anger and the frustration
comes up and a person's in a meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if i teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and i teach you a
way to change that
i always say to people
when was the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and afraid and
protected
it takes practice to to do that and and
so we we work with people in letting
them
we give them numerous opportunities to
practice this over and over and over
again and sooner or later pedal by pedal
it starts to bloom and all of a sudden
there's an authentic smile on their face
and once energy meets the heart it goes
right to the brain we have
we did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain
but we measure the heart along with it
and when the heart starts beating
coherently
in a sense of order
like like taking a big sheet jay and
going like that
the heart sends a wave right up to the
brain
and the brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and
there's the stroke volume of the heart
in order and then you see these two or
three seconds of beautiful coherent
alpha the brain is in it's it's in that
creative state then there's a pause and
it happens again and
it's it's it's beauty it's a it's a
symphony
if you don't have that mechanism you can
have all the intention in the world but
there's no carrier wave i mean
when people when they make energy reach
their heart there's an external field
that's created it's it's it's magnetic
it's it's it's measurable
and that energy
is frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering
cannot carry the thought of health or
wealth it's not consistent with it it
carries a different set of thoughts
so then
the training then
is getting people into those hard states
because once they start trading that
fear or that pain or that frustration or
trying or whatever forcing you know
control
for gratitude and they just let all that
go and i say to them listen
if you can't feel gratitude if you can't
feel love i just want to know what
you've been practicing feeling every day
because that feeling that you're
practicing is what you're always feeling
now let's practice feeling something
else in the beginning it's not going to
be easy but you got to keep following
the formula keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it
well
when i start feeling gratitude it's very
interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you
something favorable is happening to you
right so
you've just received something or you're
receiving something you say thank you so
gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different destiny
you could say i'm healthy i'm healthy
i'm healthy i'm wealthy and wealthy and
wealthy and wealthy and free i'm free
i'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying no you're not
and that thought stops right at the
brain stem
it never makes it to the body because
the body is on a different program
so then
while the person starts trading that and
they start opening their heart well
their immune system gets stronger by 50
50
in three days they start making
immunoglobulins their bodies natural
defense against viruses and bacteria 50
not a little bit
a lot that's that's one study and so
trading that
telling the body it's in the in the
environment where it already happened
and so that's when the miracles start
happening that's when people say
i'm not doing anything well of course
you're not
you don't have to can you believe in a
future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind does not know the
difference between that external event
and what you're creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to signal new genes
in new ways to change your body
to look like the event has already
occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence
in your brain and body
to look like the event has already
occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
most people in this audience
all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
no reason this
you woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought
was a possibility in the future
something new you wanted to experience
and the moment you started thinking
about this experience
the moment you started contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's 40
of your entire brain
it is the creative center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said
what would it be like to be a leader
what would it be like to be successful
what would it be like to have this
vision come true
the moment you asked that open-ended
question
you turned on this part of the brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the ceo it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain
and the moment you get creative the
frontal lobe begins to select different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what-if
question
it begins to select these different
networks and begins to seamlessly piece
them together and making your brain fire
in new sequences and in new patterns and
new combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action
mind is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind
a hologram
a vision
an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that their thinking
begins to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in theos filled
with god
they become passionate
they started to open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again that proves
then the person now is changing
fundamentally changing biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past
into living in the future few things we
can do to support our inner environment
on a daily basis ah well listen um the
first thing and the most important thing
for me is knowledge and information
knowledge is really power and
and knowledge and information about
yourself shouldn't it should empower you
it should empower the self right so when
we learn about the immune system and all
that can do and you say oh my god you
mean not every virus gets to me in fact
no and the more you the more you
understand that and the more you coax
your immune system into love and into
like we i just did this little thing on
um
on our social media where i was talking
about the inner army of order and what
would be the signal you would want that
inner army to get and so we created this
meditation and we said what would
invincibility feel like signal your body
and feel invincible how would you feel
if you had an uncompromising will
that you had more energy than you could
possibly imagine show your body what it
feels like
because it is that emotion
of invincibility that emotion of an
uncompromising world to empower your
inner world and you have the intent of
that's what it's for
wow get ready because you're going to
start creating a cadence and a rhythm
where your your body's going whoa what
what are the what is all these new
chemicals what are all these new signals
right hey it's time hey hey uh now all
of a sudden receptor sites on the t
cells go wow we got some new signals
coming from the boss here let's open up
all those t cell receptors let's go we
in fact we're we're we would love a
little fight right now because we got a
lot of time on our hands and we got all
our receptors turned on
oh i mean that that would be
a signal for your body we also know that
if you could just trade fear
and frustration and
resentment and
suffering
for an elevated emotion and truly open
your heart again and practice doing that
um
you'll heal you'll heal you'll heal
because i mean all healings happen in
the heart if your brain is a record of
the past
and you are living by the same emotions
that have defined you
for the last 10 years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals drive the same thoughts
then your body
as the unconscious mind
does not know the difference between an
actual experience in your life that
creates an emotion
and an emotion that you're creating by
thought alone
and so your body is believing it's in
the same past experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week
365 days a year and your body is
programmed into the past
and you can create a new future holding
on to the emotions of the past
how many people understand what i'm
talking about
so then
when you react
to someone or something in your life
you have a choice
that when an event changes how you feel
there's a chemical change that's taking
place in your body
and most people don't think they can
control their emotional reactions
and so then when you react to some
co-worker
or some relative
or somebody in traffic
the moment you react emotionally you are
altered chemically
and if you don't know how to control
your emotional reaction after that event
and you allow those emotions to linger
for hours or days
you know what that's called
that's called a mood
what's wrong with you
oh i'm in a mood
really
why are you in a mood
well this thing happened to me four days
ago
and i'm having one long emotional
reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for weeks or months
that's called a temperament
hey
why is she so angry i don't know why are
you so angry why are you so bitter
why are you so enchilada
[Music]
because i had this experience
seven months ago
and i'm
memorizing my emotional reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
and people wear their emotions on their
sleeve
and that's who they think they are
and they will talk about the past to
validate why they're not creating the
life that they want
so then if you wake up in the morning
mexico city
and you are not being defined by a
vision that's bigger than you
and it doesn't get you out of bed and
inspire you into possibility
and you get up
living from the old hardware of the past
and the old emotions stored in your body
do you know what's going to happen to
you
you're going to wake up and you're going
to open your eyes
and you're going to see the same people
and go to the same places and do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
and the moment you open your eyes
all of a sudden now it's your external
environment that's controlling how you
think and feel
because you have a neurological network
in your brain for every person you know
every place that you go everything that
you own everything that you do
and the moment you open your eyes and
you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the exact same thing
at the exact same time it's your
external environment that's turning on
different circuits in your brain
causing you to think equal to everything
that you know
and you told me you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
and as long as your thinking equal to
your environment
you keep creating the same life
to
change to truly change is to think
greater than your environment
to think greater than the circumstances
in your life to think greater than the
conditions in your world and every great
person in history knew this
whether it was mahatma gandhi martin
luther king the wright brothers joan of
arc the future then is created by a
clear intention and an elevated emotion
now listen closely
that you have to cultivate in your inner
environment of thoughts and feelings
but most people
by the old self are living from past
memories that are created from knowledge
and experience from something that
happened outside of them
some experience or trauma that defined
them
and getting a person beyond the old self
then
is the great work that's what we're here
for
so
we've studied motivation
and i can tell you without a doubt
that the highest form of motivation
in any culture
in any group of people
is what's called purpose motivation
duty motivation or mission motivation
you know what that is
to have a vision to change a culture
that's bigger than you to instill change
in the world
look at elon musk how many people know
who he is
elon musk he created tesla motors
you know him
you know who he is
he created an electric car
that can go from zero to 60
in less than five seconds
and before him electric cars were like
golf carts
that cr you know crawled along the road
and he said
i'm gonna do this i don't know how i'm
gonna do it but i have a vision
and i'm gonna get the best engineers in
the world and instead of creating a new
product and selling it to a corporation
i'm going to get a group of people to
share the same vision as me
i'm going to change the world by
changing our reliance on oil
and i am going to make a difference in
the world and i am going to make a lot
of money
why not
and so people said no that's not
possible and he held on to that vision
and now motor trend magazine
never raided a car
close to a hundred
they rated the tesla car 103.
it's the best car on the road
and it relies on no gas at all that's a
vision of the future i got run over by a
truck and and and i broke six vertebrae
in my spine
and i had to make a decision at that
time in my life um
because the diagnosis wasn't very good
and neither was the prognosis and
to decide if i was going to spend the
rest of my life on addictive medications
and
with surgical rods in my spine or if i
was going to see if the mind could
actually heal the body and so that was
my wake-up call uh in 1986 and
so so i just um
i was at the point where i just had to
make a decision to see if it was
actually the truth if if all of this
that i learned was the truth let's let's
apply it and so i was lucky enough to
have a dramatic change in my own
personal health and then i thought god
if it worked on me as it worked on other
people so i started looking into people
that had you know been treating
conventionally or non-conventionally and
and with a certain diagnosis
and their condition was staying the same
getting worse and all of a sudden it got
better and and i just wanted to
look at what the cause was that was
producing that effect and so
i interviewed you know hundreds and
hundreds of people that had gone through
the process
and one of the most fundamental elements
that they all had in common with there
were a lot of things that had to do with
their mind and
uh and some people had specific diets
and specific regimes some people use
certain um you know conventional
non-conventional protocols but the
commonality primarily was about how the
mind was really influencing the body and
and
they began to really take a closer look
at how
they were thinking
on a daily basis uh how they were acting
uh on a regular basis
and looking at how they feel
on a moment-to-moment basis and
and how you think and how you act and
how you feel is your personality and
your personality has a very direct
relationship with your personal reality
which means if you want to change your
personal reality if you want to change
something about your life you got to
change
and so the process of change then
becomes the fundamental process of going
from some person that's familiar and
known to you and stepping out and
beginning to make different choices and
to begin think different thinking
differently and being to behave
differently and speak differently and
feel differently and
and if you start thinking acting and
feeling differently our research shows
without a doubt
you're going to have dramatic changes in
your biology and if you do it enough
times you're going to become someone
else and the disease then all of a
sudden exists in the old personality
and not in the new personality and then
you ask the person where's the cancer
where's the rheumatoid arthritis where's
the immune mediated condition
it's in the old person i'm not that
person any longer the new model of
reality is about causing an effect
that means then you have to feel
gratitude every day for your new
experience to occur
you can't wait for your success to feel
empowered
you have to be empowered to create the
success
and when you teach people how to do this
and they move into a new state of being
they begin to create the life that they
want
how many people are still with me
but to the materialists they would say
well no
no no no i'm gonna wait for my money to
come and then i'm going to give thanks
and those people pretty much are living
by the emotions of the past
and if you're living by the emotions of
the past you were viewing your future
through the lens of the past and your
vision will fade
because when you bring up an elevated
emotion you will see the vision clearly
and leaders in history that change the
world knew how to change a culture look
at martin luther king
he talked about justice and then got
enough people inspired
that they felt empowered enough to do
something about it
people came out of the resting state
and so then you share the same brain as
martin luther king
and being defined by a vision of the
future begins to change a
culture but most people have the same
thoughts or the same intentions and they
live by the same familiar emotions and
for the most part they're in their past
how does the person become the person
they are
and why do they keep their health
condition the same and well
most people your brain is a record of
the past it's an artifact of everything
you've learned and experienced to this
moment so most people wake up in the
morning if you think that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
they start thinking about their problems
and those problems are just memories
that are etched in their brain that are
connected to certain people and objects
and certain things at certain times and
places and the moment they start
thinking about their problems they're
thinking in the past now because every
one of those problems has an emotion
associated with them
the moment they start feeling unhappy or
feeling sad now their body's in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being though
the problem is is that the person thinks
of the problem feels the emotion and
that is a thought and feeling that's a
image and an emotion it's a stimulus and
response and that starts the
conditioning process to get the body
emotionally conditioned into the past
now here's the crazy part about it yes
the familiar past
emotionally
is producing dramatic effects on the
body because the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person is fabricating by thought or
memory alone the body's believing it's
living in the same past experience
seven days a week 365 days a year and
the problem with that is is that the
environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience and the environment there's
an emotion so the person is keeping the
same gene regulated because the body's
believing it's living in the same
environmental condition so
getting that person to step outside of
that familiar known territory into the
unknown
where there is uncertainty and have them
be comfortable there and begin to think
about how they are going to think if you
are not
defined by some vision
that is bigger than you
and you are not passionate about that
vision then you're left with the old
hardware of the past in your brain and
you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information
should lead to new choices
new choices
should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions
and those new emotions should drive new
thoughts and that's called evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future when we become the living example
of truth when we actually embody this
that
there are no limits to what we can do
and i'm hopeful with human beings that
that we have this capacity
and
and of course when we believe in
ourselves we believe in possibility and
when we believe in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and i think that is
the ultimate belief
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're gathering all of this
vital data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain
and it causes jungles of neurons to
organize themselves into networks
the moment those neurons string into
place
the brain makes a chemical and that
chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way
every single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and if those feelings and emotions drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity
all of those emotions are created from
past experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then
spend the majority of their life
talking about
why they never arrive at their vision of
the future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss
you remember your wedding you remember
the birth of your children you remember
catching a fish off the coast of
manzanilla with your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went
to the casita and you cooked the
mahi-mahi and you drank sauvignon blanc
and the wind was blowing off the sea and
the sun was setting
and you made a long-term memory
[Music]
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say
i am this way because of this experience
that happened to me
15 years ago
i am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective
it means i haven't been able to change
in the last 15 or 30 years
and scientific american
a prestigious magazine
says that 50 percent
of what you talk about in your past
isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts
are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts
in a matter of seconds you are going to
feel insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts
which then makes you feel more insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says
i
am insecure
and whenever you say i am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis
trauma
disease
diagnosis loss
something has to go wrong in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
in the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they are looking at themselves
through the eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration your body rejects
viruses all the time of course it has
memorized certain viruses that you've
been exposed to
it's memorized certain bacteria that
you've been exposed to and it's beaten
those viruses not every virus wins in
the body the body has an intelligence
and it's and it has
quite a library of memories in the in
the in the white blood cells so your
body is fighting viruses and bacteria
all the time there's a constant
competition going on really so our
research shows that four days
of opening your heart
releases immunoglobulin a your body's
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses it's better than the flu shot
it's the body's natural flu shot and
that's the innate intelligence of the
body saying i got this i got a lot of
energy in fact i got a surplus of energy
in fact i'm radiating energy and now too
much around the world well now my outer
world is not controlling my inner world
my inner world now is functioning
independent of what's going on in my
outer world and now
you're manifesting your manifesto ah now
you got it now you're in a creative
state because people are coming to you
yes right exactly now you're a magnet
now you have a field right and you have
energy
to heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light and
information cells
are getting new information that that
are causing
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so
so that immunoglobulin a in four days
went up 50 percent
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then
causes another chemical to activate the
arteries in your heart to swell and now
just like when energy moves into your
sexual organs and it swells with blood
and you have energy there the same
intensity it moves into your heart
and now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel
you feel an incredible amount of love
yeah and you feel you feel you feel
whole and now the more whole you feel
our research shows
then the less separate you feel from the
things you want in your life because you
feel like you already have them you only
want things when you're in lack but when
you feel whole then it feels like it's
already happened and that tends to be
the exact emotion
that causes those synchronicities and
serendipities and coincidences to happen
in our life and you say to a person what
are you doing and they're saying i'm not
doing anything
i'm just i'm loving life i'm being
myself i'm yeah
free i'm free from the past i'm free
from my story of the past in fact i'm
more connected to the energy of my
future than i am to the energy of my
past i think that if we share
the same experiences because we like the
same things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information yeah and if we share the
same energy energy is information so
many people as an example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you then you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're
someone who's has a uh accountability
partner that that you exchange ideas
like this with and it's a different
frequency and different energy so when
energy comes together and it's
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance
then your your sensing meter is how you
feel about that person many times in
your gut or in your heart or wherever
and there's decon there's a
destructive interference and there's no
energy involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition then that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model
that we use so imagine 1 500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes and we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so
we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our truth meter
is really whether we feel it lifted
uh or we feel like we've been robbed if
you have been an experienced if you had
experience of trauma say for example and
it's created the feeling of fear and
your fear is that it could happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment
to feel that fear they just have to have
the thought about
that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time guess what system
becomes compromised by the immune system
your immune system why because you have
two protection systems you gotta get a
system that protects you from dangers in
your outer world that's that's the gas
pedal that's the sympathetic nervous
system that's a fight-or-flight nervous
system danger threat out there use all
the energy because you gotta you gotta
survive and when you survive you gotta
take care of your body so right so so
now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says well we're part of
really the other nervous system we're
the break we're the clutch
we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and and when we do then
we'll metabolize then we'll we'll
assimilate will reproduce will will
excrete properly
so
so now you got a this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function of those
lymphocytes those white blood cells that
are your inner army of protection and it
takes a lot of energy to fight a virus
in a bacteria but if there's no energy
hey listen it takes energy to raise the
body's temperature where do you think
that comes from that's part of that
branch called the autonomic nervous
system and the sympathetic the gas pedal
is part of it and the parasympathetic is
the clutch is part of that autonomic
nervous system and it's a check and
balance but so you stay in emergency for
an extended period of time
and now you're exposed to some
antigen or some
external substance some foreign agent in
our community at least people who have
relationships that are built uh from our
community tend to be more long-lasting
because they're more self-aware and so
there's no blame there's no excuses
there's no make wrong there's no
competition there's none of that there's
just this is who i am you know and i
think the ultimate goal is
when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world
is who you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and
and you know people say to me wow you're
pretty approachable and i say
well god i work so hard every day on
overcoming myself in the morning
overcoming my ego why would i want to
build it up the next day because i got
to face that guy again tomorrow morning
so why not just keep you know you know
taking those edges and smoothing them
down so that so that
you're you're less
unconscious to all of those programs
that are built in relationships when you
hit pay dirt like that when you connect
when you connect to the field when you
connect the divine whatever you want to
call it when your consciousness merges
with a greater consciousness and that
arousal creates ecstasy bliss oneness
whatever you want to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the wardrobe or the facelift or sports
car or whatever
it came from within you and so you stop
looking out there for it and now the
love affair begins and you never want to
miss a date because it's just too good
so that memory then
that is what i'm after because when you
have those transcendental moments and
you understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment
lays down new circuitry in the brain
that's what experience does and the
experience produces a feeling but it's
not chemical it's electric and it's
orderly and every cell of your body is
jiggling you know order and there and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs
your spectrum of reality is going to
broaden some conditioning
some illusion something is removed and
you start
seeing reality as it is and all of a
sudden you start seeing the part that we
edit out for survival
now you start seeing patterns and lights
and information
that are transcendent of
three-dimensional reality your spectrum
why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry's there and
now your your experience of the world
changes you get an upgrade to the to the
vr set the virtual reality said oh you
got the upgrade you got 2.0 and now it
looks different everything looks
different everybody looks different the
world look you're seeing beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together
i mean that's the blessing of an
awakening right that's where that's
where we're going here's the deal with
trauma and it's kind of an interesting
thing because when you're traumatized
some threat or some danger or some
condition in your outer world through
your senses is changing how you feel in
your inner world
and the quotient of change between the
way you normally feel in some alarm
state when you change your internal
state and move into that emergency mode
you narrow your focus
on the cause and the brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain so then
they remember experience remember
experience is better because we can
remember how they feel and and that
memory then changes the person's biology
so they think neurologically within the
circuits of that experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being
so now the person
biologically has changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why
because if the environment signals the
gene and that's the truth that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion
the emotion that you feel from that
event is literally selecting the gene
for you to begin to change and genes
make proteins and so
the the person if it's if it's strong
enough begins to wear their trauma not
just in their brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective
that it's believing it's living in the
same past experience 50 to 100 times a
day and all you need is a stimulus and
response an image and an emotion a
thought and a feeling and you're
conditioning the body into the past well
you're conditioning the brain and body
into the past the recognition that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment
or a negative emotion envy
greed whatever it may be
that's actually lowering your energy
yeah and when you get to that place
where you're experiencing that
incredible bliss right here you can you
can't yeah and even if you have the
thought the thought will still come
because we still have those stories but
the thought
will be an understanding of human nature
because you're no longer
at that vibrational level anymore you're
rising above it you know and i think
more and more people are starting to
figure that out and and
and the people in their lives are like
no my husband
my husband is a changed person no he's
not the same guy i know him i know he's
completely different and the guy is just
like yeah i feel amazing i feel great
and all it was was sitting in the fire
yes for a little bit of time until the
body finally moved out of the past into
the present moment and so
the causes of this like i always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing people are
they're they're they're getting
promotions
uh they're getting all these wonderful
things not because
of anything that they're doing
they're just different yeah and people
notice that and they want those people
in the position to make better decisions
for the whole and i think that's uh
that's how we change the world bond
university uh a university in australia
on the gold coast
uh senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team
was our community's ability
to go to
to get to that point where they're
nobody no one no thing no where no time
and i'm talking four seconds i'm talking
five seconds i'm talking nine seconds
just like just give me a second i know
how to do this they they've practiced it
enough times that the creative moment is
when you get beyond yourself when you
dissociate from everything known in your
material world turns out when you do
that and you start changing your brain
waves
your brain waves slow down into alpha
and theta
you're suppressing the memory bank of
the known self that keeps you plugged
into three-dimensional reality when you
quiet down this mechanism
now
all of a sudden you start connecting to
that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes i believe in
free will i would never tell anybody
what to believe like politically or
socially or whatever i want to provide
them the tools and give them the free
will to create life however they want
and believe whatever they want that's
totally cool with me
so those people then
that
want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed i mean and
it's not easy
because it's
hardwired deep in the limbic brain it's
just a safety net it's a mechanism so
then imagine being in the unknown
that the instinct and the unknown is
it's a scary place
wow imagine not having a body
and we practice lingering without a body
in in in an infinite space and not
without a name without a face without a
culture without a job without a social
security number without a disease
without a diet just as an awareness you
you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years
of programming and the people who
actually overcome their fear
and they trade it for gratitude their
immune system gets stronger
their genes up regulated i mean there's
just a host of
uh everything their brain changes their
heart rate variability
they feel differently and it's it's
being measured and and some of these
people
we're measuring this now in our in our
events with with reputable scientists
and and universities they're they're
shocked
at what they're witnessing on a cellular
level on a brain level on a heart level
they cannot believe
the capacity of the body i just
was i just got an email today of assign
one of our scientists said i ran this
three times
the virus
that we exposed the cell to in advanced
meditators does not enter the cell it's
outside the cell it won't a virus in
novice meditators some of it's in the
cell some of it's outside controls all
the viruses in the cell there's an
immunity so when the person's less
reactionary to their environment
there's less of response that weakens
them they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large scale small scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is you
asked if is it possible then can that
people can heal that quickly in one week
yeah because what if they create an
inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or joy or freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past
when the body is liberated and you feel
that elevated emotion
the stronger the emotion you feel from
that breakthrough the more you're going
to pay attention to the image in your
mind and now you're now beginning to
brand new circuitry in the brain and
your body's being conditioned into a new
future and the stronger the emotion you
feel and the more you pay attention to
the picture the more you're conditioning
the body over time to the future instead
of the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally
then that emotion ultimately signals a
new gene
that
up regulates that gene to produce better
proteins and the person and all of a
sudden
starts healing and we have research to
show that people can do that in four
days signal genes to reduce cancer cells
and wow just to signal stem cells to to
suppress
to go to active tissues and repair them
and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation you come with a lot of
genes and they're just a library of
potentials they're just a storehouse of
information of possibilities so then
you've got to get the right signal the
right lock into the key that begins to
select and instruct genes that cause
genes to make different proteins and you
can regulate so many different genes the
same genes you can regulate them
differently so when they up regulate
they start producing really healthy and
robust proteins and that's that's
enzymes that's tissue that structure
that's function that's hormones
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for a long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy i really think that
when the survival gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have 10 really
great things happen in their one thing
bad and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival gene is activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because
you don't want it to happen again so
what people do when they're aroused is
they start thinking it's going to happen
so they actually select the worst
case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally embrace that future
before it happens
and they're conditioning their body to
become the mind of anxiety and fear so
in preservation and in survival if you
prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
high beta
and most people need something or
someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal state and the
moment they notice a change in their
internal state then they pay attention
to what's causing it they start
developing a dependency on it right
so
it turns out that when we teach people
how to self-regulate and change their
brain waves
we could actually see then that the
incoherence the disorderliness that's
taking place in the brain you know when
you're over aroused you're overly
analytical and you're shifting your
attention from one problem to one person
to one thing to one place to another
problem to another circumstance to your
phone to your car and each one of those
elements has a neurological network in
the brain so the arousal causes these
different circuits to fire out of order
and the brain is incoherent so take two
waves that are out of phase and mix them
when they interfere they flatten out
there's no energy so energy leaves the
brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there's something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide i mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker
sitting right next to you or six feet
away and and you're judging them you're
the same arousal is taking place and
what's once very adaptive becomes very
maladaptive this is where it gets
challenging so when we teach people how
to open their focus we've done
thousands and thousands of brain scans
and they get beyond their analytical
processes and they open their awareness
and go from a conversion focus to a
divergent focus and they learn how to
relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain
so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there
when we start deactivating the mechanism
here and we get beyond the memory bank
of the known self and brainwaves move
into theta we've
we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is
sleeping but the mind is awake and now
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is wide open and
if they can regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there's a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma
gamma is super consciousness now i'm not
talking about
a little gamma i'm not talking about a
lot of gamma i'm not talking about a
really loud gamma i'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be alpha right theta would be
and if everybody could do this it's
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this it would be really hard for all of
us to do that at the same time it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to create that kind
of
order so that's how fast the brain is
and that arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy
that arousal is bliss it is the most
familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
in
that memory then that the person has
that is so profoundly different
than the feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner state
and with that experience comes a very
lucid picture
a very profound insight a download of
information
that's the moment then
the body many times rewrites the
biological program energy
is in forming matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember disease is
autonomic dysregulation
now it's getting into a very very high
frequency of order and it's sending very
coherent information to the cells and
tissues sending energy to the cells and
tissues and cells begin to emit more
coherent light and information and then
there's the disease
and there it's not
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there